hey guys we have these sonic mania
collector's edition here for you and we
are going to unbox it today and with me
is chasity who is apparently the biggest
Sonic's and it's me number one Sonic fan
chassis of Ascencio here to unbox sonic
mania the collector's edition and I'm so
excited so yeah we're gonna do this if
you guys want to see more unboxings you
know you can subscribe to our YouTube
channel we have a tons more stuff there
including Final Fantasy 12 we have a
Mass Effect Andromeda race car that was
driven around the office a little bit
but let's jump right into this always
have a trusty box cutter that I won't
just run my hand with alright gonna go
in Oh be careful please be careful I
can't wait for this to live on my desk
alright so let's take this baby out
so wait hold on let me know so there's
there's a good amount of stuff in here
chassis do you want to describe like
some of the contents so this is the
segmented collector's edition for ps4
but there's also collector's editions
for PC Xbox one and the Nintendo switch
so you can play that game wherever you
want to really but this one is window
here I believe oh I can't see you how's
it look it's so beautiful you have to
see it Joey
oh my god oh that's really nice oh
that's so nice okay so let's start
wrapping all these oh god okay check
this out
so what is that what do we have here we
have a classic Sega Genesis cartridge
but says Sonic mania on it it looks like
you might be able to actually play it
but I think this isn't right
I doubt it I think this is it I got some
warning labels here
oh here's the access code to want to
download the game yeah that's for me but
yes there's the download code that it
comes with and then here is the star of
the show right here my boy here we have
my boyfriend Sonic the Hedgehog standing
on a classic Sega Genesis console and I
believe that if you have the switch
right here you can play the Sega sound
but the thing is it requires two
double-a batteries which it does not
come with so luckily we have some one
hand don't we got some right here
excellent where do we put those in oh
boy we're gonna need a screwdriver
screwdriver yeah this is a hammer
there's a serrated knife someone cut
some bread here's the screwdriver right
here so let's open this up Jesse if you
wanna be very careful with my boy here
we go we're gonna add some batteries so
we can play the Sega sound the least
efficient screwdriver I've ever used
what is this my grandfather gave it to
me oh sorry
yo little by little gotta go fast
gonna install batteries fast good hope
it works let's try it good again hold on
does this actually adjust the volume
probably not kind that's pretty cool
that's pretty good alright again one
more time yeah awesome
alright so awesome stuff what are we
missing so we have them is this the
metallic collector's card yes alright so
we have this metallic collector's card
here it's actually pretty sturdy
it's got Sonic on the fraud and knuckles
and tails on the back
put that right there but isn't there
supposed to be a ring yes so I'm
assuming that according to the picture
it's actually inside my cartridge itself
it has like the little circuit board
right there but I think you can
following this
oh oh there you go what are you doing
Oh fits like a glove it's a nice looking
ring it is already it is it's a
beautiful
yeah that's sturdy this is that's metal
right yep but anyway you can get all of
this together with your download code
for $69.99 nice not bad I can do that
all day you can keep the box too
so the Box doubles I feel like has a
nice display for it it does everything
so if you don't want to keep this out in
the wild on your shelf you'd always keep
inside the box
thank you doing that everyone's gonna
hate us
so what'd you think Jesse as the number
one song can in the entire world
mm-hmm that's me what do you think I
think this is a great package I think
I'm very excited to keep him on my desk
and keep doing this all day that's
pretty great I was actually really
impressed by the the size of the the
model itself I thought was gonna be
maybe like a lot smaller especially like
this is pretty much yeah full-size
Genesis got a gold ring got my collector
card got my cartridge which now we know
is not an actual game cartridge it just
holds a ring you just will try to plug
it in somewhere good it's not good you
could probably put it that on to Sonic
and Knuckles and see what happens
end up playing something completely
different okay and so that was
everything that was in the Sonic mania
collector's edition what are you doing
this is gonna go
my desk oh I thought we were gonna keep
it outside display
they said it's okay Oh everyone said
it's okay they said that I can have it
so okay well anyway if you guys want to
check out the review will happen up on
gamespot comm very soon so make sure to
subscribe to our channel and thanks for
watching for all things sonic stick with
GameSpot
[Applause]
[Music]